دمار كبير
وهائل في هذه المنطقه يعني اقتربنا من
شارع صلاح الدين
شمال شرق المحافظه الوسطى ونستمع الى
الانفجارات
القويه
دمار هائل
وكبير
في هذا المكان هنا منازل عائله
اللوح تم تسويتها
بالارض نتجول في هذه المنطقه في منطقه
الدعوه شمال
النصيرات حيث القصر الذي طال كل شيء في
هذه المنطقه منازل اراضي زراعيه دور
العباده المساجد
كل شيء هنا تم قصفه
وتدميره من قبل طائرات الاحتلال
والمقاتلات
الحربيه مسجد الاخلاص هنا قصفت المقاتلات
الحربيه
ب عدد من
الصواريخ هذا هو مخيم البريج وهذه المنطقه
التي
انسحبت وانسحب منها الاحتلال
وهنا يعني ما تبقى من رصاص
للاحتلال هذه
المنطقه قد
جرفتها جات الاحتلال و يعني اليات
الاحتلال سحبت منها الليله الماضيه من
مخيم البريج دخلنا هذه
المنطقه يعني في
جوله قناه الجزيره ترصد
لكم يعني الدمار الكبير والهائل في هذه
المنطقه المقاتلات الحربيه دمرت كل شيء
الجرافات دمرت كل شيء يعني اصبحت معالم
المنازل هنا غير
معروفه كان لي
بيت هناك هذا
هو لسان حال اهل
غزه بعد انت
الحرب سيقولون كان لي بيت هناك هذا المكان
ايضا كانت تتواجد به قوات الاحتلال
وجرافات الاحتلال
ودباباته وهو كان عباره عن معتقل
للمواطنين هنا يتم اعتقال المواطنين هنا
في هذه المنطقه واستجوابهم ومن ثم تعصيب
اعينهم والذهاب بهم الى اماكن
مجهوله هذه المنطقه كانت اشجار كانت مباني
لا اثر لاي شيء في هذا
المكان في مخيم
البريج لرصد اثار
العدوان تستمعون الى اصوات الطائرات
الحربيه دمار كبير
وهائل لحق في يعني
المباني
التي قد قصفتها القاتلات الحربيه وقد
جرفتها دبابات الجرافات ودبابات الاحتلال
وعاثت فيها خرابا
وفسادا